nos preguntan si los segmentos a b y c d
son congruentes pues veamos de a ave es
una unidad porque va de menos 1 a 0 y de
c a d es una unidad porque va de 3 a 4
entonces ambos segmentos miden lo mismo
miden 1 y por lo tanto si son
congruentes muy bien vamos a hacer otros
dos nos preguntan si a veces son
congruentes pues una vez más llega a
benny de uno desea demi de uno entonces
la respuesta sería así otro más
nos dicen son los segmentos a b y c de
congruentes pues ahora a simple vista se
ve que no verdad de a a b es una unidad
vamos de menos 5 a menos 4 y de c a d es
bastante más es 1 2 3 4 5 que también lo
pudimos haber pensado como 3 - menos 23
menos -2 es tres más dos o sea cinco un
segmento mide 1
el otro mide 5 y por lo tanto no son
congruentes muy bien